alors bonjour aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler de la banane de la banane
antillaise ou plutôt de la banane de
l'uci et oui faut-il parler de la banane
antillaise est ce que la banane
antillaise c'est tabou parce que chaque
fois qu'on évoque la banane antillaise
immédiatement dit oui là il faut pas
parler de la banane antillaise parce que
tous les emplois des antillais qui sont
des relais banane pourrait être amenée à
disparaître en fin etc
bah moi je vais lever un tabou en vous
disant dans un premier temps est-ce que
nous chez les dogues nous sommes
d'accord pour faire perdurer la filière
banane antillaise c'est à dire en gros à
continuer à subventionner réponse est
oui oui oui et oui est-ce que nous
sommes d'accord pour continuer à
sponsoriser la banane de l'uci la
réponse est non non et non
alors qu'est ce qui se passe au fond ce
qui est en train de se passer c'est que
la banane antillaise est captée au
profit d'un seul eric de lucy qui
représente lui un tout petit groupe de
producteurs et autres de ses amis qui
vont tirer le profit maximum de la
totalité de la production de la banane
antillaise donc eric de lucy a mis en
coupe réglée
la banane antillaise c'est à dire qu'il
a fait de la banane antillaise une
situation monopolistique à son profit à
son profit au profit de ses entreprises
et des amis qui sont avec lui au capital
de ces entreprises
les principaux naturellement comment ça
marche
aux antilles pour produire de la banane
il n'y a pas d'autre solution que
d'avoir des fonds possible c'est à dire
une aide qui viennent et public qui est
en partie une aide qui viennent d'europe
est en partie une aide qui vient de
l'état et cette aide qui représente au
total 129 millions d'euros par an 129
millions d'euros par an cette aide est
les districts
mais aux producteurs de bananes
évidemment plus vous êtes un gros
producteur les aides
plus vous êtes un petit producteur moi
vous avez dad hélas ce qui se passe
c'est que l'ensemble des producteurs ont
été mis dans un système duquel
aujourd'hui ils peuvent quasiment plus
sortir encore une fois si on veut
produire de la banane on doit avoir des
aides sans aide pas de production de
bananes possible mais pour avoir des
aides il faut adhérer à ce qu'on appelle
une organisation de producteurs
or une organisation de producteurs
c'est aux critères de l'europe possible
à monter à partir de cinq producteurs
mais la premier verrou et quel verrou la
banane de lucie est une banane qui
s'organise autour du fait que une
organisation de producteurs dans la
banane aux antilles ça réclame a minima
sans producteur
donc du coup tous producteurs de bananes
aujourd'hui est dans l'obligation
d'entrée dont l'une des deux
organisations de producteurs
ban à marthe d'un côté et lpg de l'aude
banham art c'est pour la martinique et
le pgc pour la loi nous donc vous voulez
produire la banane il vous faut des
subventions pour avoir des subventions
vous devez nouveaux producteurs et
l'ordination de producteur il a pas
cinquante et une seule en martinique qui
et banham art et une seule en guadeloupe
quel péché ces deux agressions de
producteurs là elles sont dans les mains
berik de lucid ces organisations de
producteurs elle récupère 100 % des
bananes qui sont produites par leurs
adhérents
ça veut dire qu'il y ait un contrat qui
existe entre eux
ces deux oignons producteurs et les
producteurs de bananes gros et petits
qui sont dans l'obligation absolue de
vente 100 % de leur production à ces
deux structures organisations de
producteurs
donc je refais le schéma si je me vante
de la banane
il faut des subventions si j'ai des
subventions il faut que j'entre dans une
location producteurs en 1900 producteurs
il y en a qu une part territoire et
s'est remis aux producteurs là elle
exige que je lui revend 100% de ma
banane donc je suis complètement ligoté
cloué à cette ordination de producteurs
et c'est un gain producteurs elle est
très largement contrôlé par eric de lucy
et ses amis une fois que j'ai produit
toutes ses bananes ses bananes là à peu
près 200 mille tonnes
ces deux cent mille tonnes de bananes
sont obligatoirement revendu à ugc ban
l'ugp ban
ça c'est une entreprise pdg eric de lucy
et puis elles sont mûri par fruidor
fruit d'or qui récupère ses 200 mille
tonnes de bananes pdg de une et eric de
lucy
bingo voilà à chaque étage vous avez
eric de lucy
eric de lucy pdg mais ses amis on va
retrouver après on fera une cartographie
extrêmement précise donc une situation
de monopole total a été créée par eric
de lucy et ses amis pour capter 100 % de
la production des bananes de guadeloupe
et de martinique
et pour y parvenir larmes c'est quoi ce
sont les 129 millions d'euros de
subventions nécessaires et ses 129
millions d'euros qui partent à l'eau
pour une très grosse partie chez les
très gros producteurs les amis d'éric de
l'uci pour une petite partie pour les
petits producteurs parce qu'ils
produisent moins et ses petits
producteurs la baisse ils ont pas cette
somme
ils vont pas y arriver donc on voit bien
là que les petits producteurs qui
représenta certain nombre d'emplois
quand même ils sont régulièrement mis en
avant alors le mot est un peu fort sans
doute comme boucliers ou comme
faire-valoir par les très gros
producteurs représentés par règles de
l'uci parce que chaque fois que vous
touchez la banane en martinique on vous
dit ah mais les petits producteurs ils
vont mourir les uns envers les autres si
vous enlevez la subvention et bien moi
je vous dis n'est pas question d'enlever
la subvention mais la première chose
qu'il faut faire il faut revenir dans
les règles qui sont des règles d'équité
et la première règle d'équité c'est de
sortir de ce verrou où il est
obligatoire d'avoir 100 producteurs pour
fabriquer une organisation de
producteurs
mais il en faut infiniment moins pour
permettre la naissance d'autres
organisations de producteurs qui serait
indépendante de la ville
de monsieur de l'uci et de ses amis
écoeuré capacité à vendre leur
production ou bien et pourquoi pas à
juger paix ban ou directement à fruit
d'or ou bien à d'autres il n'y a pas que
gp banias pas le fruit d'or il ya aussi
d'autres gens qui sont d'accord pour
acheter des bananes mais l'a pour
l'instant le système il est glauque et
verrouiller le système de la banane est
bloquée verrouillé par et pour les
intérêts d'eric de l'uci et de ses amis
et ça nous on estime que c'est
totalement inacceptable
c'est une situation de monopole absolu
voilà dans une prochaine vidéo
je vais vous apporter tous les chiffres
nécessaires est d'ores et déjà vous
l'avez compris nous montons en ligne
pour faire cesser cette situation
absolument inadmissible de monopole
absolu que cette ériger un individu eric
de lucy et ses amis ça c'est impossible
ça ne peut pas continuer ça n'est pas
dans l'ordre normal ça n'est pas dans
l'ordre moral voilà à très vite pour la
suite